un spectacle son et lumière dans une
salle presque vide
cette machine qui redoute qu'ils soient
entrepreneurs emmanuel l'écuyer
travaille depuis des années dans le
secteur pétrolier sa compagnie fournit
entre autres du matériel aux entreprises
de forage et de pipelines
le prix du baril a chuté son nombre
d'employés aussi des travailleurs dont
les salaires ont tellement augmenté au
cours des dernières années qui l'ont
fait monter les coûts de production en
quelques mois à peine
emmanuel l'écuyer a dû se défaire de 75
pour cent de sa main-d'oeuvre
si ça coûte entre 50 68 dollars du baril
pour produire que des salaires sont trop
aussitôt que lui et le dessin
l'auteur nous livre ici sa pub ceux qui
ont toujours un travail sont craintifs
c'est le cas de ce soudeur français qui
voyait en l'alberta un eldorado de
l'emploi et à beaucoup de couleurs qui
vont se retrouver au chômage
et c est donc allé les étrangers passent
pas en priorité ce qui est normal donc
c'est ce qui va être délicat
les entreprises comme celle ci autrefois
très gourmande n'ont aujourd'hui plus
d'appétit pour les travailleurs
si la morosité atteint le secteur
industriel albertain elle se fait aussi
sentir chez les entreprises de forage
l'association canadienne des entreprises
de forage pétrolier avance que près de
3500 emplois seraient menacés
un nombre qui passerait à 23000 en
tenant compte des emplois indirects en
alberta l'odeur du pétrole n'est jamais
bien loin
même dans ce restaurant où c'est
davantage la route de friture qui
remplit les narines
son nom le pipeline à les cafés et
témoigne à lui seul du lien que
l'établissement ouvert depuis des
dizaines d'années entretien avec l'or
noir tous les midis des dizaines de
travailleurs du pétrole ou des secteurs
associés s'arrête ici pour manger le
gérant constate que les clients prennent
de plus en plus de repas pour emporter
est question de moins dépenser en
pourboires depuis octobre les revenus de
son restaurant ont chuté du quart quand
les affaires perdre de la vigueur du
puits jusqu'à l'assiette en passant par
les usines les discussions reprennent
sur la diversification économique de
l'alberta tellement dépendants du
pétrole
on a connu plusieurs ralentissements du
genre dans le passé mais selon certains
la province n'en a pas retiré les leçons
et j'ai comme l'impression que si
j'avais à parier je pense que on va se
retrouver dans le même bateau abandonné
après que les prix remontent
ils vont redescendre éventuellement il
va avoir plein de personnes qui vont
super prendre les culottes baissées
congo emmanuel écuyer lui a connu
plusieurs cycles de hauts et de bas dans
le passé bien qu'il ait dû faire des
mises à pied son entreprise survivra
d'autant plus que depuis quelques années
il a décidé de travailler aussi dans le
secteur de la purification de l'eau à
coeur vers 6 essaiera femmes il faut
pour est capable de se promettre
une diversification sans laquelle selon
lui il est facile de perdre la partie
ici rafai bouvier auclair radio canada
edmonton